I'm going to Vietnam, and I'm
bringing em' beer!
(All)
Yeah!
♪♪
(Helicopter blades whirring)
The Colonel:
Yo, I'd like to go over to
Vietnam
and track down all the boys in
the neighborhood and just give
'em a beer.
I'm gonna show them that this
country is still behind them.
Because I'm going to Vietnam,
and I'm bringing 'em beer!
(All)
Yeah!
I was pretty blown away that
this was actually based on a
true story.
No chance you have a
ship heading to Vietnam?
1700 hours.
Tonight?
It's the story of a guy in 1967
who, during wartime, brought
beer to his friends
in Vietnam.
Peter Farrelly:
Which is ludicrous of course.
Ta-da!
Chickie?
Tom Collins:
I can't believe you came all
this way just to bring me a beer.
It's the dumbest thing I ever
heard of.
I knew I had to play Chickie.
Ha-ha.
Zac Efron:
I love the complexities and the
emotions.
Zac Efron:
I love story of people learning
and growing
and embodying that.
You're gonna get yourself killed
over there.
It's like you said, everyone's
doing something.
I'm doing nothing.
Zac Efron, I've never worked
with an actor who was more open.
Peter Farrelly:
This is a very different Zac,
then I think people have ever seen.
Peter Farrelly:
He's just going a blow a lot of
peoples minds.
Rick Duggan:
Do you think this is funny?
I'm not doing this for laughs,
I'm doing it for you, for all
you guys.
Russell Crowe:
Zac brought everything he could,
And gave everything he had for
the roll and that was fun to be
around and fun to be apart of.
Arthur Coates:
What did you say your name was
again?
(Camera-shutter)
Chickie Donohue.
Arthur Coates:
Chickie Donohue,
is drinking on me.
Arthur Coates:
Whoa!
♪♪
Russell Crowe plays a war
correspondent who,
Peter Farrelly:
ultimately takes Chickie
under his wing and helps him
out, and leads him in the right
direction so he doesn’t get
his head blown off.
Don’t shoot!
There’s kind of a personal
connection for me because my
grandfather
Russell Crowe:
was in fact a war photographer
so it was a very personal thing
for me
Russell Crowe:
to take on a character that did
that sort of job.
Why do you guys just report the
bad stuff. That’s what we hear
back home.
Chickie Donohue:
I mean doesn’t that hurt us?
The truth doesn't hurt us.
It’s the lies.
Zac Efron:
Russell's just the coolest.
He’s a hero of mine.
Zac Efron:
Huge hero of mine.
I was amazed at some of the
details that he was obsessed
with.
Zac Efron:
It was really fun to see his
dedication to it.
I learned a hell of a lot from
working with him.
Arthur Coates:
Smuggling beer into a war zone,
that’s not the smartest thing
that I ever heard of.
Certainly not the worse either.
♪♪
(Explosion)
Russell Crowe:
That set was one of the most fun
sets
I’ve been on in many many a
years.
Russell Crowe:
It’s very easy to work with
Peter.
♪♪
Zac Efron:
Peter is one of the most
interesting
Zac Efron:
directors I’ve ever worked with.
He doesn’t specifically come at
you with rules.
Zac Efron:
He's never stuck in one thing.
Peter Farrelly:
Boom boom boom, couple more.
Andrew Muscato:
I can’t imagine a better group
of people to ultimately make this movie.
Peter Farrelly came off the
success he had with Green Book
to write and direct this.
Andrew Muscato:
Just watching all these
incredible actors
telling the story with humanity
and emotion has been very
fulfilling and exciting.
Peter Farrelly:
Background, Action!
Russell Crowe:
This film has a really big heart
and I think
Russell Crowe:
it’s a really positive
experience.
I think people are gonna love
this movie.
Hey Colonel, one more round!
This really is a powerful,
powerful story and in some ways
its-its never been more relevant.
Zac Efron:
But it’s so kind of carefully
crafted and
Zac Efron:
well written that there’s
moments where you’re gonna be crying,
Zac Efron:
there's moments where you’re
gonna be laughing your ass off
and hopefully just transported
into another time and place.
(Artillery fire)
We’re halfway home!
Halfway?!
We're in No Man’s Land!
So? I’m okay with that.
♪♪